the longer least six around the more
everyone who will become aware of his
intolerance what was maybe one thing
that has surprised you about being on
the show one thing that surprised me
about being on the show is how well I
get along and we get along as guys being
guys and one secluded area they go for
one girl it surprised me how well we get
along are you telling me that there is
no villain there's really not so fun I
mean somebody comes to mind oh not yet I
can't tell you that yeah okay this is
the talking night is fun what's the most
emotional moment than for you the most
emotional moment so far has been talking
about my grandfather with Rachel is it
like kind of sad the most emotional
moment to come is yet to come
I'm up I'll talk about a little bit more
I'll open up a little bit more hmm
there's something that's about to come
and it's a little bit of deep honesty so
it's yet to come I might have thought
about it last night and got a little
emotional to myself someone's yet to
come it's a reveal that you're gonna
make it'll be a review